[Musique]
mais bon ça monsieur chirac nous
arrivons au terme de cet enfant n'est
que rallye vos restes en quelque sorte
de l'émission donc de 4 minutes 30
minutes pour convaincre
alors je viens vous savez de ma province
viennent marseille super me provins oui
vous connaissez bien je crois pour y
avoir passé une partie de notre enfance
et que j'aime beaucoup et j'entends ce
que disent les gens je vais donc vous
poser les questions qui me posent qui se
posent à votre propos est naturellement
proposé cette campagne électorale dans
la première question peut-être un peu
provocatrice
c'est celle ci on me dit je crois que
c'est vrai que les socialistes sont en
train déjà de former leur nouveau
gouvernement
on me dit par exemple claude villers est
en train de préparer le scénario la mise
en scène de la fête de la bastille
dimanche soir après la victoire de
monsieur mitterrand alors si fichu et
vous avez même pu voir que le candidat
socialiste a décidé samedi et d'aller à
une réunion internationale et d'y
prononcer un discours dont personne jean
qu'il puisse être autre chose qu'un
discours de chef d'état
eh bien je crois que monsieur mitterrand
a tort car il ne faut pas préjuger de ce
que sera le vote de dimanche prochain
il ne faut pas avoir en quelque sorte
l'insolence de considérer que les choses
sont acquises et qu'on a une espèce de
droit à maintenir sa position et sa
situation chez monsieur mitterrand
pourraient bien être déçus ainsi que les
socialistes dimanche soit non mais ça ce
sens je me permets pas c'est ma
conviction de votre commission mais
voudrait que vous me fassiez partager
c'est à dire qu'est-ce qui en vous vous
dites que ça n'est pas perdu d'abord
monsieur facile parce que lorsque
j'engage un combat et notamment sur le
plan politique ou sur le plan économique
quand j'ai engagé le combat contre le
chômage
je considère que je dois gagner j'en
suis profondément convaincu je suis prêt
à assumer la responsabilité de l'échec
mais je suis convaincu gagner et ceci
jusqu'au dernier jour mais je ne préjuge
pas du résultat je fais confiance aux
électrices et aux actes
voilà alors bon faut dire quand même
allez un petit peu plus loin si vous
permettez j'aimerais que vous me donniez
ce soir deux raisons pour voter dimanche
pour vous je pourrais vous en donner
beaucoup plus d'1 2 2
j'en choisirai allard l'une dans le
domaine de la politique au sens noble du
terme et l'autre dans le domaine de la
vie quotidienne dans le domaine de la
politique
j'ai une majorité qui m'a soutenu
loyalement et qui continue de me
soutenir loyalement
ce qui veut dire que si je suis élu dès
la proclamation des résultats
je formerai un gouvernement qui engagera
immédiatement une politique de
redressement dans le droit fil de celle
qui l'a conduit depuis deux ans mais en
tenant compte à la fois de tout ce qui a
été exprimé par monsieur bart bien
entendu et qui est cohérent avec mon
propre projet mais aussi du message reçu
le 24 avril monsieur mitterrand dit pas
autre chose le jura qui dit moi je
nommerai premier ministe dans les 48
heures oui mais la grande différence
c'est que moi j'ai une majorité qui pour
trois ans existent et qui par conséquent
assure la stabilité de nos institutions
et permet d'engager l'activité peu
gouvernementale tout de suite tandis que
le candidat socialiste n'aura peut-être
un premier ministre essaiera par un
certain nombre de combines et aux chats
ils se produisent déjà oui sans succès
mais enfin on voit quelques-uns bien peu
et permettez-moi de le dire bien modeste
et il ne pourra pas rester dans cette
situation devra donc dissoudre
l'assemblée nationale et nous sommes
repartis si j'ose dire pour un tour
c'est à dire un nouveau débat national
sur les mêmes thèmes avec les mêmes
affrontements avec les mêmes risques de
divisions est ce que vous croyez
vraiment que face aux problèmes auxquels
est confronté le chômage la pauvreté la
concurrence économique de l'europe de
demain les problèmes de sécurité les
problèmes d'immigration etc terrain la
france
ah le temps à consacrer au lieu de se
rassembler dans un effort rapide
un nouveau débat un nouveau débat
politicien
c'est ça l'élection du candidat
socialiste
c'est l'ouverture sur l'incertitude
peut-être sur une certaine forme d'
aventure est en tous les cas sur la
paralysie pour un temps assez long des
pouvoirs publics
nous n'avons pas les moyens alors ça
c'est la raison politique n'a une autre
est une raison je dirais qui tient au
coeur des français plus que tout autre
c'est la lutte contre le chômage pendant
cinq ans monsieur mitterrand à gouverner
avec les pleins pouvoirs il y a eu sept
cent mille chômeurs de plus jeunes et
gouverner que 200 g commencer par
stabiliser le chômage pour la première
fois de plus 15 et j'ai engagé le
processus de décroissance depuis mars 87
il ya 5 % de chômeurs de moins et 15 %
de jeunes chômeurs de moins
et j'entends poursuivre cette action les
socialistes en sont incapables
ils l'ont prouvé et démontré malgré leur
engagement derrière moi j'entends
poursuivre une action tendant à répondre
à ce problème
il y aurait bien d'autres résiliation
alors maintenant elle apprend la verse
donnez-moi 2 raison pour ne pas voter
mitterrand dimanche
aussi je pourrais vous en donner
beaucoup plus de données je prendrai
d'abord la première et qui est le
pendant de ce que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure le candidat socialiste n'a pas
de majorité il faudrait qu'il trouve une
majorité pour soutenir l'action de son
gouvernement
ce qui suppose à l'évidence soit des
magouilles politiciennes qui
paralyseront l'action de ce gouvernement
soit une dissolution et un nouveau débat
national un peu paralysant lui aussi et
divisant la deuxième raison c'est que
monsieur mitterrand a fait les preuves
de ce qu'il savait faire entre 80 et 85
jamais le chômage n'a autant augmenter
jamais l'insécurité ne s'est autant
développé notamment la délinquance et la
criminalité le terrorisme aussi
jamais l'immigration a été aussi mal
contrôlée et l'immigration clandestine
si toléré avec indulgence et je pourrais
multiplier les exemples
jamais les déficits aussi qu'on était
aussi important en cinq ans la gestion
socialiste s'est traduite par le fait
qu'on a multiplié par trois la dette
intérieure de la france par quatre sa
dette extérieure par 5 le déficit
budgétaire
et tout cela cela suppose que demain
l'on soit obligé de prélever sur le
porte monnaie de nos concitoyens savidan
totalement négatif que vos prénoms et de
ses violentes sont jamais totalement
négative mais le bilan global a été
négatif
alors comment pourrait-il demain alors
qu'il ne nous a jamais dit je me suis
trompé et je ferai le contraire de ce
que j'ai fait hier mais de dire s'il
l'avait dit je lui aurais répondu si
vous voulez faire le contraire de ce que
vous avez fait hier c c'est à dire si on
dénombre r oui si vous voulez faire ce
que moi j'ai fait je suis probablement
mieux à même de le faire que vous donc
nous restons dans ce flou et cette
ambiguïté nous ne pouvons pas faire
confiance à un homme qui a échoué une
première fois et qui prétend en refusant
d'évoquer les vrais problèmes que le
site est tout à l'air obtenir un chèque
en blanc au nom de l'incantation au nom
du verbe au nom du flou je n'ai pas
confiance et par dessus le marché il a
montré à quel point il avait une
tendance ou une aptitude à cacher la
vérité à travestir la vérité aux
français et bien prête à l'usure est
falgarde je vais notamment allusion à
l'affairé gordji où son comportement m'a
profondément choqué on n'a pas le droit
de travestir la vérité lorsqu'on
s'adresse aux français bien là allons
quand même un peu plus loin je suis à
côté est bien sûr un électeurs
centristes
qu'est-ce qui vous me dites alors que on
sent qu'il ya un peu de trouble dans ce
secteur qu'est ce que vous me dites pour
me convaincre de voter pour vous et je
suis stupéfait par cette campagne
développée par les socialistes et qui
tente affaire apparaît entre leur jeu
oui c'est leur jeu mais qui tend à faire
apparaître les centristes comme des
espèces de 2 gens sans conviction
versatile moi je connais bien les
centristes ils font partie de la
majorité
ils m'ont soutenu dans les moments les
plus difficiles avec une loyauté par
fait il rien ne permet de dire
aujourd'hui que tout d'un coup ils sont
pris d'états d'âme
je les ai vus mobilisent et
naturellement ils ont peut-être plus que
d'autres des préoccupations que j'ai
intégré et qui sont celles de la justice
sociales qui sont celles de la
construction européenne mais nous
n'avons pas de divergences de vues ce
domaine
oui mais moi je fais parfaitement
confiance aux centristes et je n'essaye
pas de débaucher qui que ce soit
précisément puisqu'on parle des gens
qu'ils sont ébauchés j'en ai entendu
dire soit veux qu'ils disent est la rai
télévision qu'il avait retrouvé dans le
programme de monsieur mitterrand les
thèmes des programmes le monsieur bart
monsieur bah si moi aussi dense que je
peux appeler le programme car il est
bien léger de monsieur mitterrand je
trouve des éléments auxquels je souscris
quand monsieur mitterrand dit il faut
que tout le monde soit plus heureux
c'est un motif que je partage
parfaitement
est ce que je veux dire c'est que les
socialistes
quelles que soient leurs ambitions pour
le bonheur des hommes que je n'en doute
pas de leur réalité ont toujours été
incapable de créer par une véritable
politique économique et une gestion de
nos affaires les conditions permettant
de financer de progrès social
le progrès social a eu lieu quand y ait
lieu en france essentiellement est
d'ailleurs à l'étranger aussi lorsque
les socialistes étaient dans
l'opposition
lorsqu'ils prennent le pouvoir il gère
nos affaires de façon telle que quelles
que soient leurs bonnes intentions ou
leurs ambitions la france s'appauvrit et
s'appauvrissant qu'elle ne peut pas
financer les actions nécessaires de
justice sociale et de progrès social
c'est la raison pour laquelle on ne peut
pas leur faire confiance c'est pas un
procès d'intention sur les objectifs
c'est l'incapacité dans laquelle ils
sont de créer des moyens permettra
d'atteindre ses objectifs donc voila
voila il jean stériliser nos entreprises
en les surchargeant ils ont empêché
l'investissement ils ont ruiné les
contrer
abl en dépensant à tout vat dans les
conditions dont on n'a même pas retrouvé
les traces
ils l'ont fait avec le secteur
nationalisé ont des trous considérable
dans les déficits et par conséquent dans
ce qu'ils ont demandé à nos compatriotes
de financer c'est pas comme ça
naturellement que l'on peut financer le
progrès social
l'activité minimum d'insertion et
garantit que j'ai proposé pour être la
nouvelle conquête sociale du prochain
septennat ralliant à la reprend plus ou
moins d'ailleurs oui mais sous forme
d'assistance il il faut donner un chèque
à ceux qui en ont besoin naturellement
qu'il le faut et que la lutte contre la
priorité la lutte contre la pauvreté est
avec la lutte contre le chômage une
priorité absolue mais moi je dis qu'il
faut donner certains chèques mais aussi
mais aussi tendre la main à ceux qui en
ont besoin
leur donner les moyens de conserver leur
dignité car le fait que faisons un
effort soit d'insertion soit de
formation soit de travail et puisse
justifier l'argent qu'ils gagnent et la
protection sociale qu'on leur assure
c'est un problème de dignité leur avance
ont un peu je suis par hypothèse
toujours électeurs du front national
qu'est ce que vous me dites donc je vote
pour vous dimanche
j'indique simplement que sur les
principales préoccupations qui peuvent
être ce qui d'ailleurs ont voté soit à
droite soit à gauche
dans un vote protestataire le 24 avril
je leur dis simplement comparer ce qu'a
fait monsieur mitterrand est ce que j'ai
fait comparer ce qu'il dit et ce que je
dis vous êtes inquiet pour la sécurité
voyez le lam horse de rétablissement de
notre sécurité et que je poursuivrai
vous êtes inquiet pour le sauvage voyez
que mon gouvernement et le premier qui a
lutté efficacement contre ce fléau
social
vous êtes inquiet pour la sécurité
sociale voyez que mon gouvernement a
rétabli l'équilibré des comptes qui
avait été si perturbé par la gestion
socialiste vous êtes inquiet pour
l'identité nationale voyez comment j'ai
lutté contre l'immigration clandestine
comme on j'ai fermé nos frontières et
que je les ai contrôlé et je pourrais
multiplier les exemples vous êtes
inquiet sur la façon dont on va aborder
l'europe
voyez comment j'ai redonné aux
entreprises la possibilité
l'idée d'investir et donc d'être
compétitif comment j'ai défendu les
intérêts de nos paysans à bruxelles de
nos industriels de nos artisans de nos
commerçants des professions libérales
pour qu'elles abordent cette europe de
demain avec toutes les chances d'être
victorieuse est jugé à partir de là qui
par son passé par l'épreuve qui n'a
donné par ses ambitions plaire est le
mieux à même de satisfaire vos propres
ambitions alors offre mais c'est jacques
enfin je suis tenté par l'abstention
dimanche
qu'est ce que vous me dites pas que je
ne mentionne pas c'est vrai que certains
peuvent être tentés par l'abstention
je voudrais mettre en garde
d'abord parce que s'abstenir n'est pas
une attitude responsable
devant l'importance des enjeux devant
les problèmes auxquels nous sommes
confrontés nous devons prendre position
le courage et je dirais le sens civique
nous y oblige
à partir de là si ce qu'a fait monsieur
mitterrand entre 80 et 85 vous a
convaincu du bien fondé de sa démarche
si le flou actuel de son propos ses
incantations vous conviennent et si vous
êtes prêt à lui donner un chèque en
blanc alors oui voté pour lui mais si
vous doutez de cela référez vous à ce
que j'ai fait dans des conditions
difficiles pendant deux ans et alors
votez pour moi mais s'abstenir
en toute hypothèse et vous devez le
savoir et le comprendre s'abstenir c'est
voter pour monsieur mitterrand et par
conséquent contre ce que vous pensez
profondément ce que nous trouvons de ma
soeur nous parlerons de monsieur le pen
du racisme la nouvelle calédonie et
c'est à de m'asseoir adobuzz
[Musique]